What do you think about using ivermectin as a cancer preventative? Well there are studies
that are out there that ivermectin has helped people with cancer so that is another protocol
that you could use. You could get ivermectin and take it as a cancer treatment. As a cancer
preventative? Well what is preventing cancer? Well you're trying to get if you're truly preventing
cells from optaging toxins that can damage the DNA then it's just trying to live the best lifestyle
you can so that you're not exposed to as many toxins but the truth is it's literally impossible
to not be exposed to toxins. So if you're defining prevention as that you'd ever get a diagnosis
of cancer because it's helping your body kill it prior to it ever getting to the size that it will
ever be diagnosed then i'd say yes could be a preventative so as you know taking medicinal mushrooms
not having cancer and i'm taking you know you take mushrooms anyhow you know you take immune
stimulants and you know aloevia immune product and you know probably saccharides and you know
calculated and other good products so that you don't get cancer
are you you're taking it so you can kill it before it ever becomes cancer too so you're due you are
doing that as well so yes i think that would be something to take. I don't personally know a number of
people that take i've ever met them literally daily or they they um more people that pulse it they
might take it three days a week and and you know they're not taking you know just to tell you they're not
taking a prescription they're taking over the counter buy it at fleet farm typeplaces the pace for horses
um and uh they have swored by it for years that really helped them through covid and um
um they're literally there's there's uh different pages that you can get on different groups that
you can get on that there's thousands and thousands of people are the group that are doing this
so um there's no side effects to that so you take it a very low dose